this country loves promote pharmaceuticals
POV you have nausea and you discover Zofran
did you know the Zofran has a
black box warning
and that it causes maternal heart issues
also causes cleft palate when taken
in the first trimester of pregnancy
that's when doctors prescribe it the most
it still just blows my mind every time
that these are literal advertisements
that pop up on the for you page of my TikTok
God forbid we explore the root cause
of why you're nauseous to begin with
possibly be drinking alcohol or
black coffee on an empty stomach
or antibiotics or
birth control
or pesticides
herbicides
inflammatory foods
chronic stress
couldn’t possibly be any of those things
that's so stupid so
instead just order Zofran